حسنًا ، يجب أن يبدو ذلك جيدًا وأنجز في
الواقع ، فقط عدت إلى الأبراج
الآن خط النهاية الرسمي الخاص بي ، لقد واجهت
الكثير من الاضطرابات على طول الطريق لدي
22 ماراثونًا مع التسمم الغذائي
وأصبت بعدوى في الكلى لثلاثة
أشياء كثيرة  حدث خطأ كما يمكنك أن
تتخيل ، ولذا فأنا محظوظ حقًا
ويسعدني تمامًا تجاوز
خط النهاية هذا في التاريخ الذي حاولنا
الانتهاء منه والذي كان قريبًا جدًا من
عدم حدوث
[موسيقى] كان
عبور خط النهاية أمرًا
مميزًا  الوقت الذي كنت أعمل فيه جنبًا إلى جنب
مع كيفن وعدد كبير من الأصدقاء الآخرين
الذين ركضت معهم مع كيفن ، والذي كان
مصدر إلهامي وراء هذه الرحلة ، كان يعاني
للأسف من سرطان البروستاتا ،
وقبل أربع سنوات عندما حلمنا بهذه
الرحلة التقيت كيفن  خرجت في
الصحراء الكبرى في الفم تحت البكاء
وانطلق هو وأنا وكان هذا النوع من
الدفع الكبير فوق الجرف إلى
عالم المغامرات وأظهر
لي حقًا ما كانت تدور حوله الحياة
[الموسيقى]
كل شخص
حقيقي من التعرض للهجوم  و بت  عشرة من
الكلاب التي سُرقت بالسكين في
نيجيريا ولاغوس صدمتني سيارة
كسرت مرفقي ولكن في الواقع كانت
الأمراض هي التي كانت المعاناة الحقيقية
لأنه كما يعرف أي شخص عندما تكون مريضًا
حتى لو أصبت بالزكام  لا
أرغب حقًا في النهوض من السرير ولكن
عليّ أن أخرج منه وأقوم بماراثونين أو ثلاثة
أسبوعيًا ثم أصعد على متن طائرة
وقم بذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا
وعندما تعاني من
التسمم الغذائي أو  عدوى في الكلى
عندما يريد جسمك حقًا التوقف
ويقول فقط انظر ، أنت تعلم أنني بحاجة إلى
التعافي ، ثم أذهب للنوم دون
أن أتناول الطعام ، ثم أستيقظ الساعة 4:00
صباحًا للركض قبل فتح أي شيء
ثم اذهب  وأجري ماراثونًا
ثم انتهي ثم اصعد على متن طائرة
، وهكذا كانت هناك أيام أعتقد أنني أمضيت 35
يومًا دون تناول أي طعام في اليوم
وأجري ماراثونًا وهذا ليس
مثاليًا
لك